there is a canadian professor who is
under fire right now
for encouraging young girls
to prostitute themselves when they are
young
as they are beginning to start their
careers naomi sayers who's an adjunct
professor at the university of ottawa
tweeted out quote unpopular opinion
the best thing young people can do early
in their careers is do hashtag sex work
on the side because your early career
prospects will be unstable unpredictable
low pay likely contract work and very
much exploitative
now a spokesperson for this a spokesman
for
for this woman is saying she was being
ironic she was making a criticism of
capitalism
so she's saying don't don't believe that
this woman's actually encouraging
her students to prostitute themselves
but then later on
the same spokesman said that this is
just part of her point on the shaming
and slut-shaming and sex work so then it
seems like she is defending
prostitution and the kids to go into it
so this woman's obviously very confused
she does make a criticism of capitalism
she says that's how capitalism
works people out here saying young
people can be exploited in sex work
literally that's capitalism law and
quite literally that's any kind of work
any kind of work abolish capitalism
abolish actually abolish prison but
whatever
so this woman obviously has a couple
screws loose
she is a communist she is an insane
communist but i repeat myself
but i actually want to take her point
seriously because i think she
unwittingly is revealing something
about the modern left and frankly the
modern right
she shares some critiques of modern
society
with conservatives she is saying that
some aspects
of the current economic system are
exploitative and that in some ways by
making an idol of mammon
making an idol of of gdp making an idol
of these things
we are neglecting other important
aspects of our society and our humanity
in the name of boosting gdp a little in
the united states
we ship our manufacturing jobs overseas
we destroy communities in the united
states we sell out the american worker
that's just a fact is that because of
capitalism is that because of our
corporatist regime is it because i don't
know why you use whatever term you want
capitalism itself is a word popularized
by karl marx
but that that criticism of our current
economic system is one that i bet this
woman would share this crazy communist
and i bet traditional conservatives
who care about the american worker would
share right that is an error that is a
problem
but what this woman is suggesting which
you get so wrong
is she's taking this materialist view of
humanity
whereby we are our bodies
we have no dignity we have no soul we
are just
meat and so for her if you're using your
body
to make widgets at the factory or you're
using your body
to be degraded by men on camera or
in a bordello or something then
it's the same thing but they're not the
same thing
when you use your body and your mind
to create something you are
maintaining your dignity when you
degrade yourself and you turn yourself
into an object
a a mere play thing for someone else's
pleasure you are
undermining your dignity can
actually consider sex itself i think
this is why they go so crazy with the
sex work
a wife and a prostitute engage in the
same act
right i think it's the same thing
why do we think one of them
is good and one of them is bad
well what this woman would probably tell
you what the left would tell you is
because of the patriarchy it's deluded
us and it's given us crazy conceptions
and
actually it's the same thing and it's an
exploitation of men or whatever okay
the reason we think that is because one
of them is happening
out of love in a stable loving place
that gives dignity to the woman
and the other is exploitative it's
really two people exploiting one another
it's the man exploiting the prostitutes
desperation and the prostitute
exploiting the man's desperation for sex
right the the man exploiting the
prostitutes
need for money and greed for money
and the prostitute exploiting the man's
addiction
to sexual pleasure and his need for
instant gratification and his his
degraded view of the world
that is a mutual exploitation a husband
and a wife in a loving marriage
will the good of the other person they
are building something there
it's not a zero-sum game where they're
just like i'm gonna take this from you
and you're gonna take this from me
you're right you're actually procreating
in that situation you're creating
a child so they're they're physically
they look like the same act but they're
totally different acts what this woman i
suspect is saying is actually there's a
really conservative
argument here what she's saying is when
women are younger
let's say a woman in her early 20s
should engage in
sex work she's saying that because women
who are younger
are more physically attractive they
should take advantage of that
turn it to their advantage and make some
money out of it i bet what the
conservative would say
is actually when a woman is younger what
she should do is get married she is more
physically attractive
she's got more energy more energy to
raise kids whatever
and so yes they're observing the same
physical facts
but coming to totally different
political ends
this woman unfortunately she's gone
totally totally wrong in her view of
things
but we can actually learn from the left
sometimes we can learn from their weird
perceptions of the world that is
actually one of the main points of my
upcoming book speeches controlling words
controlling minds
i want to take the left seriously on
these things i want to take their
thinkers
seriously you know so much
of this craziness on race
and sex and gender quote unquote comes
down to
a misunderstanding of really basic
philosophical questions
this is why this this racial narrative
has become a kind of national religion
it's got religious
ceremonies that's why juneteenth is now
a national sacred feast a religious
holiday
it's why pride month is on the
liturgical calendar because we don't
understand the religious underpinnings
of society hey i'm so glad that you
liked
that video there's a whole show there's
an entire episode out there that you can
get what's the title
knives at a gunfight head on over you
can check it out on youtube
on the apple podcasts app on spotify and
stitcher on google play and you can
pre-order my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds ring
the bell subscribe we'll see you next
[Music]
time
you